people traveling for the first time  since the coveted shutdowns there is a  warning now from the better business  bureau  because scammers are now targeting  vacation plans they're using offers that  are just too good to be true  things like vacation rental cons free  wi-fi scams they even pretend to be  hotels in some instances  so if you're booking a vacation rental  just watch out for con artists who post  listings for homes that aren't even for  rent or they just don't exist  google that on the side and keep in mind  many travel companies will advertise  free vacations  but that doesn't always mean the trip is  entirely paid for there's always strings  attached so watch out